avec nous Anthony Durocher sous
commissaire à la direction générale de
la promotion de la concurrence bonsoir
Monsieur Durocher bonsoir alors votre
rapport se penche sur le marché de
l'épicerie de détails est-ce que est-ce
que le Bureau de la concurrence a
observé des infractions des preuves de
collusion ou d'abus de position
dominante au sens de la loi qui vous
réjouit
la premièrement c'est important de
comprendre que notre étude ne visait pas
nécessairement faire en quête sur des
agissements de concurrentiels mais
plutôt d'étudier s'il y a des barrières
à la concurrence vraiment dans le but de
faire des recommandations auprès de tous
les nouveaux du gouvernement pour
déterminer comment qu'on puisse aussi la
concurrence dans le secteur parce qu'on
sait que la concurrence est très
importante pour les consommateurs pour
diminuer les prix augmenter le choix
donc c'est vraiment le but de notre
étude c'est de faire des recommandations
pour qu'on puisse avoir plus de
concurrence dans le marché mais la
question qui était sur toutes les lèvres
monsieur Durocher au moment où vous avez
entamé cette étude là c'était à savoir
est-ce que les épiciers ont profité du
contexte inflationniste pour augmenter
leur marge de profit est-ce que vous
avez une conclusion à chapitre là c'est
sûr qu'on étudie si la dynamique
concurrentielle a changé si celle-ci
avait un effet sur les prix et pour ce
faire on a fait des demandes
d'information auprès de les gros
épiciers pour mieux comprendre
l'évolution de leur marge ces dernières
années ce qu'on observait basé sur
l'information quand même limitée qu'on a
reçu c'est que les marges brutes des
grosses épiciers ont augmenté de manière
modeste mais quand même significative
depuis 2017 donc ce que c'est nous dit
c'est vraiment qu'il y a place à plus de
concurrence dans le secteur vous dites
que ça a été difficile pour vous là
d'obtenir toutes les informations
souhaitées pourquoi est-ce que les
épiciers ne vous ont pas offert toute
leur collaborations effectivement le
niveau de coopération qu'on a reçu de la
porte des grosses épiciers pour notre
étude et était variés il y en a certains
qui ont coopéré plus que d'autres mais
de manière générale on peut dire que ça
n'a pas été complet puis pour nous on
regarde ça dans le contexte que nous
pouvons pour les études de marché si on
ne peut pas demander aux requiert les
parties de nous donner toute
l'information dont on veut donc on doit
nécessairement faire face à la
coopération puis l'information qu'on
reçoit de manière coopérative ou ce qui
est déjà dans le domaine public donc
c'est sûr que ça nous limite un peu avec
toute l'information qu'on aimerait avoir
mais néanmoins on était en mesure de
faire une étude à s'approfondie du
marché puis faire des recommandations
qu'on juge importantes pour augmenter la
concurrence dans le marché bon si ça
vous dites là ça prend une stratégie là
on veut attirer des épiciers
internationaux sur le marché canadien on
veut mousser la concurrence à part
Costco et Walmart il y a pas de grands
groupes là ni les français Carrefour ou
les Américains publics par exemple qui
se risquent à prendre pied au Canada
vous les avez contacté justement
qu'est-ce qui les retient monsieur du
rocher les facteurs qui retiennent les
gros épiens internationaux sont vraiment
spécifiques pour chacun leur modèle
d'affaires puis plusieurs ont déjà
étudié le marché canadien mais ce qu'on
a observé dans notre étude c'est que
les gros épiciers ont vraiment eu un
impact avec leur entrée dans d'autres
pays par exemple en Australie si on
regarde d'un gros épicier comme Aldi qui
est rentré dans le marché on a vraiment
vu un impact direct sur les prix et le
choix de l'innovation dans le secteur
donc c'est pour ça que une de nos
recommandations c'est vraiment que les
gouvernements encouragent l'entrée des
épiciers internationaux parce qu'on voit
que vraiment ça peut avoir un impact
important pour la concurrence et pour
les consommateurs et favoriser ou du
moins épauler les épiciens indépendants
également monsieur du rocher exact les
épiciers indépendants sont très
importants aussi surtout dans les
régions rurales à travers le pays il y
en a plusieurs mais c'est clair que
c'est difficile pour eux de faire
concurrence au gros épicés puis c'est
pour ça encore une fois une de nous
recommandations disent que les
gouvernements soutiennent dans la mesure
du possible les indépendants plutôt que
les gros épicés et vous dites aussi que
l'accès aux épiceries c'est assez inégal
selon qu'on se trouve en ville ou en
région éloignée d'autant plus que la
plupart des épiciers imposent des
clauses restrictives de propriété où
elle s'installe est-ce qu'il faudrait
interdire le contrôle de propriété
permettra tous les commerces
d'alimentation qu'ils veulent de
s'implanter dans un même quartier mais
c'est sûr que les clauses restrictives
ont un effet important sur la
concurrence parce que bien souvent ça
prend un magasin ça prend l'immobilier
pour se faire puis les clauses
restrictives peuvent empêcher les
indépendants les nouveaux entrants de
rentrer dans certains marchés surtout
dans les régions rurales donc c'est très
important puis une de nous
recommandations c'est de c'est que le
gouvernements cherchent à limiter
l'utilisation de ces clauses ou même
peut-être les bannir complètement aussi
parce que elles peuvent avoir un impact
important sur la concurrence un mot
interminant c'est du rocher sur
l'affichage harmonisé des prix on doit
être on doit l'imposer
oui on juge que c'est important d'amener
ça pour vraiment s'assurer que les
consommateurs puissent être informés
puissent faire des comparaisons entre
certains produits puis avoir une
meilleure idée de le prix d'un comparé à
un autre mais c'est clair ou Québec le
Québec est un quand même un bel exemple
pour les restants du Canada parce que il
y a des gens un système en place pour
qu'il favorise les primitaires mais pour
le restant du pays c'est quelque chose
que on conseille
d'y porter attention puis en particulier
regarder le bel exemple du Québec
à vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI